well i think when most people hear the
phrase new age
they associate it with all of the
uh i guess you would call the modern or
recent or unanchored spiritual
movements that's come out of california
i think when the section of the public
that is
fundamentalist in its orientation hears
the phrase
they think of it as a neo-pagan
outbreak uh probably driven by
devil worship and that sort of thing uh
when when an occultist is the phrase new
age
they think of madame blavatsky and the
golden dawn
and all of those people around the turn
of the century who were also
talking about a new age so
obviously it has different connotations
for different people
it's a group of religions it's an
impulse in other words you can
consider yourself new age if you simply
embrace
wheatgrass diets or you may
have to embrace channeling or healing
with crystals
or shaping your life
through affirmations these are all
cliches of the new age and a person may
subscribe to some of these things
and not others
i see it as a as a fundamentally
it's fundamentally shaped by an impulse
toward the irrational
and my argument with it is that it seems
to
lack any ability to do
critical evaluation of itself
so the new age is more fiercely
uh a religion even than the old
mainstream religions are it seems to
consist of a lot of people whose
position
is my mind is made up don't confuse me
with facts
it's characterized i suppose at its core
by a weakness for gurus
for lineages which is always a
substitute for
clear and rational thought and analysis
so in a way there's very much about it
is not
new it is a
pagan it is non-christian
it's uh got its roots in
as i said theosophy and
crowley and magic and astrology some of
these things are legitimately
neopagan echoes and some are
in fact new face made up out of whole
cloth
i'm thinking of oh the followers of the
urantia book
or something like that now that was
channeled in the 20s
but a very significant percentage of new
age people
are are intellectually friendly to that
sort of thing
well what you really have is not a
conscious
mass movement but many many small
movements that have all been lumped
together
not by themselves but by the media
i mean the media phrase new age
basically refers to this vast
unstructured group
of cults belief systems i mean
a person can be can consider themselves
new age i suppose if they just practice
affirmations and
try to keep their cholesterol low well
that's a
far cry from uh signing up
at the solar temple and giving all your
money away and beginning to
use multivite suppositories
[Laughter]
i actually saw moldavite suppository
man for sale where did you see them with
where was this what are they anyway no
no
moldavite i'm sorry i'm deeper in this
[ __ ] than i
realized moldavite is a glassy green
mineral that is created when asteroids
impact the earth and it forms into these
little things
called tektites which are
considered in the new age to be
extraordinarily
healing and i don't know energetically
charged or something uh this this is an
idea that gems and minerals and crystals
have healing properties
that the the new age has brought back
basically from renaissance uh fergie and
magic but it's one of the ideas
very typical of the new age crystal
healings crystal pendulums
so forth and so on in my public
comments on this speaking from the point
of view of being a psychedelic advocate
i've been known to say that the new age
will embrace
almost anything as long as it can be
assured that it is not effective
in other words i'm occasionally placed
in the new age
because no one knows where to put me but
the new age is
very phobic of psychedelic experience
that's just a bit too real for it
uh i think it's that the impulse to
watch your diet and the impulse
to uh form your thoughts with
care at least you put bad vibes out into
the world
and the certainly the impulse to care
for the environment
these are healthy impulses to greater
and lesser degrees
but the sense of moral superiority
the elitism the
gimmickry the dependency on
unproven and exotic technologies
and the general lack of any sense of
historical anchoring
makes it to me a kind of
pop phenomenon i guess that's what i
want to say
it's very pop very few
new agers probably themselves even
realized that
madame blavatsky began talking about the
new age
in the teens and twenties of this
century
so i see it as a phenomenon
in response to alienation i guess
it's people who feel uncomfortable with
orthodox christianity don't
want to embrace agnosticism or
atheism or secular humanism
and so then there is this uh
fire free zone of hundreds of cults
uh some incredibly demanding
demanding your money your celibacy your
loyalty
and others very laid back demanding
nothing more than
that you drink your daily dose of
wheatgrass juice and check your
horoscope
i'm amazed at it's the
way this thing has persisted and spread
and caught on and i conclude from that
that people are desperately
looking for spiritual answers and they
are not
very critical in their evaluation of
what is offered to them
in the late 19th century probably
under the influence of the british raj
so that you had a lot of british
administrators of india who for the
first time came up against
yoga reincarnation and the whole
smorgasbord of indian spirituality
and these people were themselves
alienated from the religious
offerings of of victorian england
so they began to write about these
things and organize
themselves and they uh w b
yates was part of it and aleister
crowley
a.e weight and
the uh sister of the french philosopher
henry bergson was married to
s.l mcgregor mathers who was one of the
founders of the golden dawn
well then the golden dawn fell into
schism
largely due to polarities set up in the
organization by crowley
who some people let me just talk to you
for one second you know well the golden
dawn was
part of of the pre-raphaelite movement
it was it it had yates in it
and mathers and a e weight and
all of these people and it was sort of
the umbrella organization
that emerged out of this impulse to
study and understand um
eastern thought and madame blavatsky and
gurchief
also there was an influence there were
these different schools and they
sometimes found common cause and they
sometimes
railed against each other madame
blavatsky seemed to be the best
organizer of the group and
the golden dawn flourished up into the
20s
and the 30s i don't know exactly when
she died
she handed it on to annie bessant
and they established centers uh
in large cities around the world in san
francisco
in london berlin so forth and so on um
but there was a lot of um
internal dissent in the group over the
role of
magic and uh and sexuality
and whether these were legitimate paths
to experiment with
and the straighter people stuck
with the the golden dawn
and crowley and his crowd
broke from it and established the order
of
de lima and it had other names
and then in the 20s
was the first great surge of this kind
of
thing even in southern california and
and there were magical working groups uh
austin osmond spare was one of these
figures there's a whole
pantheon of of people and writings
and there have been some very good books
published on the interneting
politics that went on i am not an expert
about all of this
expert but then it all seemed to sort of
die down in the 30s i guess maybe
intellectuals turned to marxism
or that generation of people sort of
died out
madame blavatsky became very interested
in krishnamurti
he uh resisted
you know these these groups wanted to
proclaim him
the world messiah and he basically told
them
to get lives and get real and that he
was not the world messiah and that he
didn't want that
laid upon him and krishnamurti is an
interesting figure because he
resisted all of these impulses and yet
was at the very
center of it and in the 20s is when the
urantia book was
channeled and uh
oh the kellogg with his dietary
obsessions and it this thing had
all kinds of elements to it it was a
religious
thing it was a magical school it was a
critique of
diet it was a critique of orthodox
christianity
and then as i said in the 30s it seemed
to go underground or fade away
marxism and and fascism on the
other end of the spectrum seem to claim
intellectuals attention the bloomsbury
people and all that
and then uh in the
late 40s after the war it all came back
again
you had the betty books betty white
and her thing you had the first ufo
sightings and
it the rosicrucians were establishing
themselves in san jose california
and it seemed to grow steadily
through the late 40s and the 50s
generally in southern california and
even back then
it was a joke and a cliche that
california was a pretty
nutty place you know you had people like
amy simple mcpherson
these fantastic preachers who
did these shows which were part
preaching
part busby berkeley type productions
and then the 60s came along
and because of the influence of
psychedelics i think
and because of another wave of interest
in the east
this thing always seems to be to get its
intellectual juice from surges of
interest in eastern thought
for the early wave madame levski and all
those people it was
india well then in the early 50s you get
people like
daryl suzuki writing about zen
and alan watts and
krishnamurti was still alive at that
time
and psychedelics created uh
an interest in these things psychedelics
were never
embraced by the new age although
certainly
crowley was the drug user
a very cosmopolitan drug user
and and then it just sort of as
the drug taking of the 60s was repressed
and people got scared of lsd
and all this they were now speaking a
language of
vibrations and
affirmation and meditative
visualizations
tibetan llamas tibetan buddhism became
very chic
there was a lot of sexual permissiveness
and underground experimentation
the flying saucer cults were developing
in parallel i know this all sounds very
messy but it was
messy in the sense that a yogic
ashram has very little to say to a
flower to a flying saucer cult
and neither has much to say to
an astrologer and yet all and much more
besides
are legitimately considered part of the
new age
it was it went from being a a
fairly i think genuinely motivated
fringe group of religious impulses
that was then subverted by commercial
interests
that i think were much more cynical and
people who took a look at it and said
well how can we
configure this into saleable
products how can we market this
as a series of 10 lessons how can we
make this something which we can sell
and in the 70s is when
this all came along and
you know if things were not bad before
they were certainly much worse
after because i think the level of
cynicism
is incredible i mean people who lead
cults preaching abstinence and
avoidance of sugar and you name it are
themselves
you know completely at ease violating
whatever they've just been preaching to
the masses
it certainly doesn't corner the market
on that i mean you have your
jimmy swigerts and that sort of thing
but the new age
uh when it went big time when it
got to be big money i think a lot of
very cynical people
moved in dumbed it down got rid of all
the stuffy victorian esotericism
and packaged it in bright colors
and made a lot of money with it
i think that a lot of people who have
not been taught
to think critically are being victimized
that's absolutely right this heaven's
gate thing is a perfect example i mean
i've been hearing interviews on npr and
people are saying well to meet these
people they were very intelligent
very well spoken well that's not how i
remember it i remember in 1975
when the leader who then called himself
uh
beau and pete his female consort
were going around they were saying they
were extraterrestrials
and somebody said to me you want to go
hear him and i said
are you kidding that's all i need to
know i mean this is a con
so i don't know what kind of
intellectual standards are being applied
to this stuff
but uh you know i've taken a very
cynical approach
toward a number of new age phenomena
and i've been right every time i mean i
was right about
s i was right about bow and peep
i'm not interested in fire walking i
think the urantia book is nonsense i
and but i sometimes find myself in
situations where
i'm with people who
whose decency can't really be
challenged what seems to have happened
is
a real failure of the educational system
to teach people how to distinguish [ __ ]
from shinola you know
you see that's perfect but just don't
say [ __ ] and shine over say something
else like
their rear end from an elbow or whatever
yeah well people who are unable to tell
um uh the real thing from
a cause and um
i this is a deeply troubling problem to
me
deeper than the issue of the new age
because i
get up in front of audiences and say
quite strange and startling things
well now if i were a member of that
audience i would ask
hard questions and resist but often
my audiences just they would they would
go
further than i am willing to go and
i think that what has happened here is
there is a conf the new age is extremely
hostile toward what it perceives as
science or scientific thinking western
quote unquote
yes and what they have done is they have
confused
science with rationalism
and so they reject rational
thought well that leaves you
just no place to stand
if you reject reason what tools
do you have at your disposal well
heidegger answered this question he said
you must measure things by the depth of
the call
but you know a lot of people look at the
nazi thing and the way it related to
heidegger and say
well this is what you get when you just
measure things by the depth of the call
nobody can deny that the nazi message
stirred the german blood the call was
deep and broad and strong
it was also morally bankrupt
uh jonestown another situation
where obviously these poor exploited
ghetto people
felt the depth of the call but in the
absence of reason
it it turns into
a nightmare my fear for the new age is
that it has thrown away the tradition of
rational discourse
and by doing so has left itself open to
uh the most dramatic the most compelling
orat oration advertising and marketing
and this this will not
lead to happy results i think people
should be open to
unusual and even irrational experiences
that reason prosecuted
too intensely leads to a kind of
constipated conservatism
uh i the whole if if i were to juxtapose
the psychedelic
subculture with the new age subculture
the main distinction is the psychedelic
subculture is built around an
experience the psychedelic experience
make of it what you will the new age is
based around
for all its denial of the fact ideology
uh meaning you know the belief that we
all once came from
mars or the belief that atlantis once
ruled the world
or the belief that one can channel
beings from other dimensions
but always belief not a stress
on direct experience and i think this is
where they've gone
uh as wrong as you can go
i agree rational discourse and
analytical styles of thinking are are
fairly recent in the west
but in fact it was the creation of those
techniques that allowed the west to
escape
from the endless cycle of cultic
thinking i think the new age is
responding as i said
to the pain of alienation but it's
responding in a
in a foolish way it's not responding
at sufficient depths and
i don't know really what you do about
that all
organized religions whether we're
talking about the roman catholic
church or the cult of the coming saucer
fathers
can agree that psychedelics are very
dangerous
and that's because psychedelics make it
very difficult
to deliver your message no matter
what your message is you know a very
interesting thing
about christianity i read in the past
year i read a
book i can't remember who wrote it but
it's called the christians as the romans
saw them and it's a whole bunch of texts
from the early days of christianity
by roman administrators and commentators
and suetonius is one of the first people
to write
about christianity and he said of it
in his report he was the governor of
armenia or something and he wrote a
report
for the emperor and the emperor
specifically asked him he said
is it a religion and suetonius wrote
back and he said
no religions deal with the great
questions of
man's origin and his destiny this
is a cult of christ
and you know of course this is very
controversial to say today but i think
suetonius got it pretty close to right
and because western religion because
christianity
has this cultist within it
it has always then been susceptible to
to cults and uh so
you know people don't get it that the
moral life
is led by clothing the naked
burying the dead caring for the sick
comforting the afflicted and there's
several other things along that line it
is not
achieved by wearing white not eating
meat
uh or giving up sex or
wearing certain kinds of amulets around
your neck
people have gotten out of touch with the
fact that religion
is about moral behavior
and if you're in a a group that tells
you you can achieve
some kind of salvation without caring
for your fellow human beings and
behaving morally
then you are in a cult well i think
in that sense it's taking its cue from
psychoanalysis
uh you know psychoanalysis promulgated
the idea that you could talk your way
from mental from neurosis to health
and in a way uh in a way
psychoanalysis is part of the new age i
mean the relationship between freud and
jung
to blavatsky gurjeev and some of these
people
is a fascinating study in itself
so uh yes there is a lot of disease
in the world there is a lot of
alienation in the world
and if you speak a rhetoric of of
completion happiness brotherhood
and community uh people are going to
follow you
the problem has been to actually deliver
on these on these promises
well i just say to people you know if
you think
i'm a guru then you are not listening to
what i'm
saying the wonderful thing about being a
psychedelic advocate
is that the psychedelics can speak for
themselves
they don't need terence mckenna to act
as the apostle paul
and interpret it so
to my mind the wonderful thing about
psychedelics is that they are democratic
that you know you can do it i can do it
the guy down the street can do it
it isn't about lineages or how many
years you've
served the master or how many years
you've been
celibate or anything like that and all
these
other methods somehow
uh establish an automatic elitism
you know that those who advance must
necessarily be
somehow better and in the psychedelic
world we know
those who advance are not better they're
[Music]
braver
[Music]
do
you